did you fake type run did you see Chris
chilly echidna war with those Logan guys
I only know about it because young Jaime
young Jaime informed me that it might
have been one of the most epic battles
Chris so funny man yeah he owned them so
hard to the point where I whatever the
guys name is is like oh he's making fun
of a young kid or something like he
calls himself like young or he calls him
an old man like that's old man making
fun of a young whippersnapper
yeah young people always like to point
that out yeah you're older yeah I think
it's hilarious is it because they're so
terrified of getting old
yeah like everybody is so like there's
this thing or so I make fun of you you
broke look you bro
you're [ __ ] 36 years old does that
mean it's almost over bro 659 thousand
likes he said at least when my career
dies you can film it and put it on
YouTube remember suicide before why is
Logan Paul he's responding to his oh I'm
laughing cuz now I know why your comedy
career took a dive oh Jesus he owned and
so then Chris says to him that yeah at
least my career dies you could film it
put it on YouTube that six hundred and
fifty eight thousand likes more than
Trump in any tweet chumps ever had
it gets a strong men is now strong that
that that response is that's like the
strongest response I've ever seen with
this is Logan response to that say but
not gonna lie this single tweet is funny
than your entire Netflix special thanks
how does it feel to have your name
finally attach to something funny oh my
god oh my god I don't know what's worse
being the shunned vlogger or being the
38 year old comedian arguing with the
shunned vlogger on Twitter ask your fans
to have their moms read this tweet out
loud
see what they think that's good oh my
god
oh my god he's the wrong guy to [ __ ]
with he'll do this all day
old people roasting me greatest thing on
earth how about this you're my son tag
your [ __ ] daddy I mean what's the
thing that you deleted damn powerful
crystal yeah I can love it hard in the
paint Christa funny dude man did his
Instagram stories or some of my
favorites anything Chris does it's
pretty [ __ ] funny Wow
so far you've called me daddy and
admitted to watching my entire comedy
special are you trying to burn me or
[ __ ] me okay